speaking of sports movie our next guest
actually if i'm not mistaken
is uh got a script making one uh which
is one of the many reasons why i love
checking in with nate boyer because you
never know
what this uh long time green beret
former
long snapper in the world of college and
professional football is up to
and we all know he is part of merging
vets and players he founded it with jay
glazer now five years ago
our friend nate boyer is here on the
show how are you nate
i'm good rich i'm a walk-on you are
okay i'm a walk well walk on and i grew
up a notre dame fan because
uh the local team was the cal bears and
they weren't very good
and so i just like you said you just
adopt it
when you're in berkeley california you
so you were like you grew up like what
am i going to root for the cow bears
and you try to root for the notre dame
fighting irish what you did now
are you saying hold on a second nate
because this would this would crush me
and my argument into many pieces did you
are you saying rudy was an inspiration
for you
[Laughter]
okay fantastic um how are you doing
by the way i'm doing good i'm doing
really good how are you doing i am doing
well
um how are uh i guess people that you
know
uh in the veteran community doing let's
let's start with that uh to kick off our
memorial day weekend conversation here
nate yeah well you know that's uh
that's case by case for sure but you
know what i think during this time
i've been really really proud of a lot
of people and yes
like isolation's one of the biggest
killers figured figuratively and
literally uh for
for the veteran community and obviously
everybody's feeling a bit of that right
now and it's really hard
but i'll tell you what like the
resiliency and the way that
that uh the vets that i've been that i'm
close to whether they're
a big part of of mvp of merging vets and
players
or not have just they've found things to
do
um ways to be of service i mean
especially here in la
i've just like countless stories of
these guys and girls going way out of
their way to find a way to help uh
somebody get something done you know
somebody that can't can't do it on their
own and like they just
times like this happen and it's like
they come alive it's like a deployment
you know it's an opportunity like okay i
got a mission now
something to fight for like what can i
do there's got to be something
because you know we're we're a mess
right now as a country in a lot of ways
so like how can i be
utilized and that's been really
inspirational well i i do know and part
of the reason why i wanted to
bring you on this week uh weekend in
particular nate is it was about a year
ago at this time i i attended my first
emerging vets and players uh i guess
wednesday night
uh workout and then post workout
sit around confab and by the way by sit
around comfab and this is what's so
amazing about your organization that you
founded with jay glazer
at vetsandplayers.org is you get
together
work out work your body and then work
your mind
afterwards and sit around and talk about
veterans and players
fresh off of their playing careers just
discuss about what's going on in their
minds and how they can feel
a part of the world and
that memorial day weekend in particular
is the toughest weekend for many
uh who have fought and served and i want
to give you the floor as to why and how
everybody can go about their business
this weekend
and make sure that they don't say the
wrong thing and actually
do the right thing absolutely yeah i
appreciate that rich
you know it's uh it is a tough time it
can be like
like a very somber weekend and you know
we're
obviously memorializing that's why it's
called memorial day those that have
fought and paid the ultimate sacrifice
and a lot of us the better community
served alongside those people became
very close with those people they were
our brothers and sisters uh not only in
arms
but literally became our brothers and
sisters i mean you're on a deployment
overseas
i went on three of them which is nothing
compared to some people i i know guys
that have been on 13 of them
but you go over there and maybe you
don't know anybody when you first
get there on your squad or whatever
depending on how you deploy
but you become incredibly close with
them incredibly fast uh
you know you're you're living with these
people and then you're out there
training um and then you're in a combat
situation potentially
shedding blood alongside them it's like
you
bond with those people in it in a really
really tight way
and then when you lose one of those
people it's very it's very hard in the
moment
uh and it doesn't go away it's not
something that just uh
passes with time it's always there um
and it's
and it's days like this that can be
really challenging it definitely can be
really challenging and
you know all of us in the vet community
um especially when we're done serving
you know we lose a piece of that
identity and purpose
and that sense of belonging to something
bigger than us
and uh and so it can be such a challenge
but there's
there's so many ways to look at it
though too and that's something that we
preach in mvp
is like understanding that you
sacrificed and risked so much um
to fight for those that can't fight for
themselves right and
because you did make it back maybe you
maybe you've been living with survivors
guilt
but you also have survivors
responsibility to live
a life in honor of those that didn't
make it back
you have that responsibility so today uh
or i should say monday
probably every day should be somewhat of
a day of inventory and i stole that from
somebody a medal of honor recipient but
it's a great quote he said
memorial day is a day of inventory we're
looking at myself
saying am i doing all the things i
promised i would do when i signed
when i signed up when i took that oath
when i met uh
in my case my my best friend brad
overseas and i told him i was gonna go
try and be a you know football player
and then when brad's gone like am i
am i gonna do that am i fulfilling that
promise am i am i going to chase that
dream because if i'm not
um that you're not living up to that
promise for them
you know what i mean and the last thing
i would want is them be looking down
from heaven and saying
you know in their heads like nate what
are you doing what did i die for man
i mean come on you know i i don't want
you to cry for me every day like of
course i want you to miss me we all want
to be remembered
but like how are you living your life
are you are you chasing are you chasing
down what you said you were going to
chase down are you pursuing that
that american dream of yours because
that's what i want for you and because
that's what that's what i would want if
i wasn't here and i'm pretty sure
everyone's in that same boat and that
includes people that have died by their
own hands back here at home you know the
suicide epidemic's a big one and it's
really
hit the veteran community hard so with
all that being said like just
make this a celebration this day should
be a celebration
honoring those people remembering those
people have a hot dog have a beer
and go on a hike and get closer to them
do the murph challenge
in honor of michael murphy something
like that to like remember those people
this day but enjoy it and celebrate it
and in terms of that nate i mean
obviously those are incredible words and
powerful words and hopefully any
veterans out there as you say who have
survivors remorse so we're just hearing
us and watching us can hear that
but in the final set of moments i have
with you here what about
uh mere civilians i i remember that
there was
a request of uh civilians
what to say on memorial day
that would not perhaps send somebody
in the wrong direction if they are
remembering and grieving
while trying to celebrate the memories
yeah i mean you could
you could say thank you in in various
ways you know but also say
i i would suggest saying something like
you know and i understand
this might be a really hard day for you
um but i just really want you know i
appreciate
you and i appreciate everybody that i
didn't get to meet
uh that didn't make it back that you
that you you know fought alongside or
you're remembering
and uh if there's anything i can do to
help just let me know like i wanna help
you
i want to fight for you you fought for
us you know i think that's the that's
the best way to do it just to show that
you're that you care
you know you're listening there's not a
perfect phrase or anything like that but
just to understand that like
first of all veterans day memorial day
are different things um
you know but also just like it's not
supposed to be
to me anyway it's not just supposed to
be this downer day
it is a celebration we're we're
remembering the date you know it's a
it's a holiday
for a reason um but just you know have a
little bit of
sensitivity and spot in that you know
especially you're out on well
maybe people aren't on the beach like
normal but you know you're right out in
the red white and blue and doing the
things there's nothing wrong with that
i just understand why we're doing it and
if you you know come across better make
sure and thank them spend a few minutes
talk to them and then just let them know
that you know your thoughts are with
them and like you appreciate not only
their service but those that aren't here
today
love you nate thanks for calling in man
and what you and glaze do
for uh for for vets and players merging
vets and players
uh vetsandplayers.org being the uh
the website um awesome you take care of
yourself
you too rich love you brother right back
at you that's nate boyer
went back and forth towards a duty also
with the university of texas remember
pete carroll in seattle gave him a shot
that's right this is great
yeah great dude